all right so today is Saturday December
19th
so TIFF Isaac and I are flying to Dallas
Texas today to visit my family and
before we go on the flight though we
have a lot of air institute and we have
about four hours to really do everything
I'm asked to JK office right now to pick
up a hard drive because I need that hard
drive to go bring some work back with an
elastic so I can stay working on some JK
stuff and then once I get all that done
feed all the cats if he picks we'll make
sure the water is good I'm gonna pack
all right we are all packed what else we
gotta do and that's it this guy's ready
to go and we're on our way to Dallas
and we are back home it is it's 12:20 8
a.m. you should have already been in
Dallas right now but no the stupid
flight got cancelled and then we're
gonna fly out tomorrow morning at 7:30
in the morning we have a show picking us
up at 3:45 in the morning Ivan told me
when we were coming up the stairs right
here he was like mommy you just went to
the airport just to visit yeah no it's a
joy no we had dinner at the airport s
what we did is such always a time and
big ol headache and everybody with his
we could have bought a hotel but I'm
like now just go home and see your
kitties what a good mom do you like how
we didn't go to Dallas you did I'm
quarters I like that mr. positivity over
here yeah you like the hustle and bustle
huh it's exciting for him good night
guys good night
what we're going here what we're doing
here yeah so it's 4 o'clock in the
morning we're back Elliot
waiting for flight eating some food
really tired only slept for two hours
what about you Casey like you are good
but I really want to say and I'm very
jet-lagged
I'm very jet lag I bet I could sleep I
can not even sleep in the airplane right
now I just feel like I could just lay
down gorgeous
one minute kuba
you're not tired over here like so
took me a while to get the champion on
the record
hello you're on another level
Sammy
you're excited face
that's it that's the American Airline
spirit Isaac we're going to Dallas
I'm not even excited to go see my
parents right I'm just excited to go
find a pet the tiredness is over right
at the excitement of Dallas what do you
think about mommy's costume
oh my gosh get there you thank you up
he's getting heavy huh yeah
grandpa daddy over there alright just
landed in Dallas just got picked up with
my parents and we were walking over to
the car we are passing up the car I
passed it already logging again yeah
thank you you're still very strong
here just lazy they're hardworking
people
hello what are you happy to see me of
course anytime
I never realized how flat Texas was
until I went to California and saw
mountains and actually lifts besides
mountaintops I'm not used to not seeing
mountains in the background oh where
dancing
the brothers here and the brother
girlfriend is here
and the girlfriend is here and the mommy
easier daddy is here and the monkey is
here you can do it yeah oh hey Pete
well someone needs to record what I'm
recording and documenting something for
some purpose what I was doing when you
were young we have a lot of data like
this when you were young yeah I do I
have a lot of baby footage all right if
we are now home at my parents's house
residents how beautiful is neighborhood
is gorgeous like we're in Europe
beautiful I love his neighborhood watch
guys check this house out I freaking
love Casey's family's home so pretty he
spoiled little brat okay it comes out
now ha ha ha ha hello Freddie okay
chalid a yeah right yet the best
childhood you spoiled kid just to make a
note this isn't the house that Casey
grew up in sit still look at how
gorgeous houses
I six looks like he's ready for bed he
just goes he's like I already know where
my room what are you doing Isaac I'll
bet your bat fly away hey here we go
some exercise until Deb cut your toes
okay
oh you're a little kid you should be
able to do this this should be easy
yeah oh yeah tickle fight guys you know
you know what I kill him I brought them
into this video getting them out it's
like your science experiment it's like
one of those things were so
a doctor has some medicine and then put
it inside of you and become a superhero
and then you break free right you know
how to get get there or not
when I go no one's listening to me all
right
just finished taking a nap and then we
napped for like like 4 hours trying to
correct our a jet lag his ever since
Japan we'd never really fully recovered
from our sleeping schedules
and then the whole missing the or flight
delay and all that stuff doesn't really
help you here so pretty tired
it's about dinnertime now and we're
gonna go eat cafe saw Sarah food for the
first time I'm actually pretty excited
so yeah I got a whiff of these two now
all right I am clean shaven and we are
dressed for dinner took a long nap he
doesn't want a grin camera right now
kind of cranky he had a pretty long nap
making him cranky a little bit cranky
too okay I'm not I'm just hungry all
right we just got the Deep Ellum Texas
we're about to walk in a cafe saw Sara
it's actually the first time I'm walking
at the cafe saw so since they opened
back in the summertime and we actually
shot a music video we shot a commercial
about six months ago so this is my first
time returning back the cafe saw Sara
so the hostess in the commercial I
returned this is cool this is cool
Hey I was expecting a Latino working
back behind the counter what happened
how do you like being a manager of a
restaurant
it's all right and this place looks
totally different than our commercial so
I guess we shot the commercial way way
back when before a lot of these neon
lights were installed this is uh looks
pretty good surprise it we're we're yet
cafe saw Sarah I love your hairstyle
yeah you look like Thunder trouble
that's what you have followed trust
everything even knows you've done okay
all right so I don't think I mentioned
this yet but cafe saw Sarah is my
family's restaurant and it is a Latin
Caribbean restaurant in Deep Ellum Texas
and I'm actually very excited to try the
food
hey have you ever had a horchata a latte
yeah but uh happy saucer tea
and we came correct usually they sell
most Mexican restaurants it's always
powder and you could like taste only
cinnamon you can never take sexual
rights with this or test something drink
already dry okay I'm down look up there
uh I'm not a big cocktail person - amber
you gotta try the velvet hammer fell
beverage time free to get to me you
gotta try this
alright so the sound imbalance yeah most
vocal it's a lovely bright no beer you
got a lot of local beers everything out
of here is local you in this mission
part this is a suicide it's a cider beer
but with a college suicide are from
Bishop arts area and then you got
Franconia grease you just draw McKinney
well that's 9 percent what - I percent
really good it's real smooth real keep
song in in that flavor and you don't
like crackers I mean I like here but
you're very selective
I think you like this one what are we
doing right now with making cha-cha-cha
right in your cha-cha cha-cha check it
was too sweet
a contract attorney cha in Chinese ot oh
you got people a few they don't know
what it is what the heck is it you think
you would sell better
well now whoever sees this is gonna know
the Hong Kong invention so let a latin
american stop started by a Hong Kong
mando so you know that words look at the
key like pop it on my cutting salient
pole opposed to oh is it multiple drinks
to drink I saw that tanning here like
dogs who drinks way freely than with you
you did better you did half way I think
this time one more time I'd say it start
from the start for the beginning in
didn't even job oh that's great lady
thank you oh the lighting is great
Oh hold on here we go photo shoot time
Chicka Chicka Chicka Chicka the light
you [ __ ] up the light car there we go
keep it steady
oh they're leaving thanks for great
thanks for all the help